Remember when you learned about for loops, if statements, functions?
Those are fundamental concepts in programming, and if you're
ever writing code in other languages, you'll see these concepts again and again.
Now, the same goes for certain concepts with code organizations.
Here are some of those main concepts that you'll see over and over again.
The first on our list of fundamental organizational concepts is models.
Now, we've already talked at these.
Models just represent your data,
and models can be stupid, like a JavaScript object literal as shown here.
Or they can be more intelligent, as in most other organizational frameworks, and
as we'll see in a bit.
Next, we have collections.
Collections are basically smart arrays.
And what are they filled with?
Models.
Now, remember, models are just data.
Even if they're intelligent models, they still represent data.
So, collections of models are collections of data,
just like our cats array in the previous lesson, but a little bit smarter.
Now, we've talked about octopuses at length, but if you bring them up
to any other developer, they won't know what you're talking about.
Octopuses in the real world are called things like controllers or view models.
Here's another thing we've already talked about in-depth before.
Views are the things that draw the interface and
allow the user to interact with the interface.
We also have a similar thing called routers.
Now, this is new to you technically, but only kind of.
Routers keep track of the state of the URL, which in a way is a view-like thing.
The URL is something that the user can interact with and see.
Often, routers are used to track the state of the application.
Now, we're not going to get into routers in any more depth than this,
just conceptually.
But just know that they're very similar to views, just for the URL bar up here.
Don't be afraid of them.
If you can understand views, you can understand routers.
Now, organizational libraries often look very different from each other.
But no matter which you use,
you generally see these same five things over and over and over again.
The concepts are all the same, and
that means once we have a solid understanding of these basic concepts,
we can feel empowered to learn new organizational libraries.